inestabilidad e incertidumbre dos
palabras que por estos días definen el
sistema bancario estadounidense que está
sintiendo los efectos del incremento de
la tasa de interés por parte de la
reserva Federal para controlar la
inflación
los nervios ciertamente están tensos en
este momento
de los pasos más importantes que el
congreso puede tomar ahora es asegurarse
de que no haya duda sobre la plena fe y
crédito de Estados Unidos
la atención se produjo a principios de
marzo cuando silicon y signature
debieron cerrar ante la pérdida de
recursos que se produjo con el alza en
la tasa de interés y la reducción en el
valor de los fondos del tesoro
por otro lado la falta de liquidez del
prestamista First Republic Punk obligó a
otras instituciones Establecer un
rescate por cerca de 30 mil millones de
dólares para evitar su colapso pese a
todo lo anterior el gobierno
estadounidense niega una crisis
financiera
quiero asegurarle a los miembros de la
comisión que nuestro sistema bancario
Sólido y que los estadounidenses puedan
estar seguros de que el dinero que han
depositado estará disponible para cuando
lo necesiten
se encuentra en un momento delicado y
por ello solicitó más de 50.000 millones
de dólares para fortalecer su liquidez
no obstante a pesar del incremento en el
valor de sus acciones entre los
depositantes hay temor debido a la
importancia de la banca para la economía
del país